you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens this end we are back live
on the game spots co-op stage here at e3
sponsored by lego star wars the force
awakens I'm your host Chris waters and I
am joined by andrea renee i just seen n
jeff cannata we're gonna break it down
talk about our favorites talk about what
we want to do and talk about what we
hope to see from these open world games
so who's got one we want to start with
look you've been taking lead here yeah
let's go yeah he would take took the
lead last time Oh No leAndria Oh a new
game new IP announced from Ben's days
gone I'm gone open world so here's the
pitch to they told me I saw the behind
closed doors mmm yeah open world
action-adventure sandbox right so those
are a lot of keywords let's bring it
down right not Barbie so fun to like
games yeah right got a motorcycle okay
well I heard it down to like five games
so one of the key things about to an
open world is locomotion how do you get
around that world you don't want to be
hoofing it everywhere I motorcycle is a
pretty dope way to get around and the
the guys in the development team told me
that they designed the open world with
the motorcycle in mind because you know
one of the other people in my demo a
swell how big is this open world because
that's always like the first cycle size
how big is the map and so they were like
well we're gonna we want you to traverse
it on your motorcycle and so I think
that's an indication that's gonna be big
and cover a lot of area and they're also
got some opportunities for sweet jumps I
want to do that thing that's in Marvel's
captain america civil war when the
winter soldier like takes that bike from
that dude and then in one motion gets
off for that he liked the guys driving
out and he just takes it and gets on it
yeah I think halo hijacking a ghost is
your best bet for that I think there's
gonna be zombies riding motorcycles
around but they do it it makes me think
of dead rising the kind of motorcycle
you're plowing through crowd a zombies
hey we're getting another one of those
two nitee because i had sort of this
nostalgia feeling of when the xbox one
first came out that like the only thing
I had was dead rising so I was like all
right I'm gonna
this so just kind of seeing that and
kind of going back to the little dead
rising it was like this is cool all
right kids back yeah and even watch dogs
to me set in San Francisco I love like
walking around places that I'm familiar
with the only Grand Theft Auto like
walking around like the Third Street
Promenade in LA it's like kinds of
things like that feeling of really
feeling like you're in it but like this
crazy world like saints row like doing
things that you could never actually do
in places that you shouldn't really be
so I love that sort of open world feel
of just I could do whatever I want I
could waste a lot of time on the side
question like a car in actual San
Francisco I actually probably can
there's a lot of time it's a problem
it's true so that that's a good contrast
to bring up you know days gone we have
this world and you know as far as i know
that's not like an identifiable lumber
mill that you can go out and find like
they've created this world whereas san
francisco they're going out of their way
to put you know all that Coit Tower the
bridges all this these neighborhoods in
San Francisco they've even completed a
building in that that is not currently
complete the tallest building in the
watch dogs trailer is the Salesforce
tower that's just going up now it's only
about that tall this tall it's really
cool I mean this looks awesome this
looks really cool like it's just so
great if you've ever been to San
Francisco and it's such a beautiful city
so to be able to sort of like tour that
and live it in a game see like this kind
of stuff in VR would be pretty cool I'm
just gonna go ahead and say that I even
though that visually they are really
impressive I have a little bit of open
world fatigue I think that there's a lot
of games to play a lot of great game yep
and open world games demand so much of
your time not just from an exploration
standpoint but it's like fetch quest
over here and an escort quest over here
and run over here and get this thing and
then come back and put it here so
collect all these little trophies all
over the world and it's just a lot of
these open world games have so much
filler that it's becoming exhausting
well that's why I think I spent so much
time in fallout 4 because everything I
did felt meaningful because there was so
much story and every side quest was so
dense and so rich and even stuff that
was just sort of fetch quest where I was
cleaning out another building of you
know
irradiated humans I still felt like I
got stuff out of that and it it felt
like good time investment rather than I
gotta collect 12 of these or you know
pick up the musical notes that are
floating around the whatever it and I
hope that people take that to heart and
and create a density of experience not
just a breadth of experience and us play
zelda correct yeah what did you think
cuz that maps I mean seemingly from the
things that I've looked at in some the
gameplay it looks huge it it feels huge
and it right now feels sparse I think
they're holding a lot back but it
already feels like it has polish it
there's some magic to that world and
you're you know you're automatically
doing everything and my mind is
absolutely blown by what is going to be
stuck in that world I know you know that
Zelda is all about secrets hidden
everywhere little puzzles and Link can
climb any surface he's Spiderman in this
game I'm not kidding how did that I can
climb anything it gets tired handy falls
down please tired and I nose down but
then there's food you can craft that
makes you less tired and there's so
there's gonna be stuff that's hidden
everywhere and this massive world it's
it's it's daunting how much time is
gonna this game is going to require but
already it feels like a magical
experience I'm enchanted by it already i
don't i like what an ji said about like
you know being sort of that fatigue like
there has to be we can't play them all
now you have to pick and choose because
i feel like you get so invested and you
spend so much time but like it's just
like a part of like your life you know I
mean Zelda I feel like do they even say
like how long you could slay forever
Brecker yeah like Skyrim is forever
right yeah I get you get the more DLCs
so it really these things can be
never-ending so it is something that
you're like all right I gotta pick and
choose cuz you can't do it all and I
also think that you can't you give
yourself a break when you're playing an
open-world game like you get into it if
you're not feeling it you don't have to
play it anymore and but I'm totally
guilty of this of like I I have to go
back to it i have this game it's a
60-hour game that's no small investment
i gotta keep going i got at least get to
a certain percent or get to a certain
level right in it open world games yeah
they feel like a big commitment
I think what they do best or one of the
things that when their best for me is
when there is a lot of stuff around but
I'm moving through it organically like
in The Witcher 3 i'm going from thing to
thing I'm discovering stuff and I'm just
following my nose I'm not necessarily
following a quest and to make that
satisfying to make just being able to go
from like thing that pops up it's a
thing that pops up and not feel like
you're checking boxes on in this area of
the map to unlock you know whatever
bonus for completing this stuff right
but feeling like I'm on this adventure
yeah yeah yeah I think I think that
honestly it has a lot to do for me with
incentivizing my questing rather than
assigning me quests rather than just
having a guy go do this because I told
you it's more like like in Far Cry
FarCry doesn't really know every up
because that's one of the games like I
am so obsessed with like far cry primal
I felt like I was like I just did this
in the last one so I had that feeling of
like all right I'm ripping down posters
you know before and then primal the
travel time yeah I was just walking
around forever yeah yeah but it's that
game is like I want a pouch I want a big
a pouch yeah somebody got money enough
yeah and I think that incentivizing you
to go out into that world is it goes a
long way to making it more fun yeah i
think what Ubisoft is doing with their
new titles with both ghost recon and
wash talks to with not just
incentivizing you but also making it
about player choice that was a big theme
that we saw their press conference like
we wanted you choose how you play so
when they did that Ghost Recon
demonstration thanking me by the way can
we talk about though can we talk about
the Ubisoft demonstration school of
acting which is let's let's be real
ridiculous yet jeff cannata up there
he'll sell you again I'll tell you again
he's got the enthusiasm that's genuine
check your six guys all right Sarah got
me covered I got you covered let's do it
you're the best well wildlands i think
is an interesting one andrea because
this is a game watch dogs is a game
where you're one guy and you're kind of
going around doing your thing in a world
that's debts
wildlands is a vast world but it's
there's a lot of space in between where
the action is happening and I think that
is because the it seems at least to me I
haven't played it you know just this
based on my impression I ghost recon is
a game about sort of getting in
accomplishing a thing and getting out
it's almost more like metal gear solid 5
you know you're not necessarily just
running around Metal Gear Solid mad oh
let me let me crap this thing or do that
I it's a different style a different
take on the structure of an open world
yeah I think it's interesting that you
know they were letting you that choose
your path but also choose how you play I
personally am like a guns blazing go in
and like wipe everybody out kind of
doing both yeah I'm like yeah let's go
but they're letting you stealth your way
through major portions if not all of the
game i think they said you can play it
all not lethal yeah just amazing we are
you know for a shooter it seems like a
pretty lethal game yeah but I'll to our
Ghost Recon it's not what well yes yeah
but you know in Assassin's Creed I also
sell went in and killed everybody want
to fight everybody um I just like it's
that sort of feel lure of you know the
more powerful hardware that we have in
this generation of games both on PC and
on console that they allow you to do so
much more in the open world like when I
walk to a far corner you know if I walk
inside a house or like this guy is in
right now on screen like maybe I'll find
something specifically in that building
or maybe I'll have a vantage point so
they like you said incentivize you to go
to these different parts of the world
but on one hand and while that's super
cool it's still super exhausting Ghost
Recon to me I was not impressed with I
mean it does look like multiplayer metal
gear solid which I guess is a cool thing
but it just felt like a mash-up of a lot
of other stuff I'd already seen and and
there is a little bit of open world for
taking me at the list of open world
games here it goes on and on and on
mafia 3 we haven't even talked about and
horizon zero dawn I mean at least
horizon zero dawn which for me is right
at the top of my list of the best stuff
I've seen here I got a chance to play it
just the fact that you are in a world
that I've never been in before you know
that Ghost Recon world I feel like it's
kind of just cause it's kind of Metal
Gear Solid its kind of its like a
million things I've already done but
horizon zero dawn being in that place
with that those creatures to discover
and take down and tame and ride I mean
to that man I think a lot of that sort
of freshness of the world is a big thing
yeah talking about choices and we were
just talking earlier off-camera about
Detroit becoming human how awesome it is
to be able to have that choice where
they're like oh you're gonna have these
choices of moral choices and you
actually have to like make a decision
and that's gonna impact it even just
like the short demo that we did I was
like how many renditions of this scene
could there possibly be because it
almost does seem endless depending upon
what you pick up we're also talking
about how I was like this dude is out
there with some small child and you're
in there like oh dude to do yeah I'm
just pick up chance you're joining right
0.o check out did you pick up the fish
do you not pick up the fish cuz I'm
Charlie actually killed outside well
couch is a huge part of open world and i
think that watch dogs to trailer they
showed that had you know the
protagonists doing one thing and then
overlapping doing the next the next and
it's all different stuff did a great job
is kind of illustrating that variety
that's one of the things you know that
fuels an open world kind of game is the
variety of gameplay experience forza we
didn't talk about that yet either oh
yeah for sure yeah and there's like
probably no guns in it even oh yes you
dixit overthrow P&I don't even do its
australia the outlawed guns there we go
smart thinking in I that forts a trailer
was really hot and the horizon series
has been just I'm not a huge racing guy
I don't say that an abrasive man it's
fun yeah get out getting out there in
the countryside and just kind of driving
and following a road somewhere you know
fault I following the road is like
that's the metaphor that's the that's
the dream of an open world for me and
the witcher i did that all the time I
just see a path and I follow it you know
I'm in a car you just where is this
gonna take me and just go for a drive
yeah I I just wished that game with
let's burn out
I saw that trailer now please entities
can we do a crash mode please somewhere
yeah I love it I final thought my
favorite thing about horizon zero dawn
and also Zelda I not a lot of overlap
there but the creatures in the world
there's wildlife it's not just you your
enemies your allies the world has to
feel like it's alive I think that you
need is more than zombies and your old
motorcycle buddies well they said that
they design that world to try to kill
you at every single turn they said it's
a very dangerous open world that's what
they said they're like a lot of these
open world games are today's awful
zombie bears confirmed is that what I'm
hearing right now be bears there are no
zombies there freakers okay freaky so
it's a giant rave everyone just getting
their freak on trying to bite your face
off oh it's one in a wonderful video
games a lot of cool open world games at
e3 a lot of hours in our future to be
playing those games in lame all right
folks can't wait that's a look at all
the open world games that we had time to
talk about in this segment don't get us
get on us if it's not a comprehensive
list just go to gamespot com and look up
all those games yourself we'll be back
live on the stage talking about Japanese
games with alexa ray corriea just a
moment
you